[Music]
I'd like to
uh begin this song I wrote about
ceaseless yearning and NeverEnding want
with a poem of popular petrarchan
paradoxes by Sir Thomas Wyatt the Elder
I find no peace and all my war is
done I fear and hope I burn and freeze
like
ice i Fly Above the wind and yet I
cannot
arise and not I have and all the world I
seize
[Music]
upon I want what I can have need what I
can want have what I don't have what I
want what I can have need what I can
want have but I don't have what I want
what I can have need what I can want
have but I don't have what I want what I
can't have need what I can't want have
what I don't have what I want what I
but I don't have it feels like all I got
is lost on a bad B Gone with the last
train honey don't you f every cloud is a
silver line and just a little rain just
a little rain just a little
rain I want what I can't have need what
I can't want have but I don't have what
I want what I can't have need what I
can't want have what I don't have my
mind won't stop and my heart says go
nobody knows how to hold me my mind
won't stop and my heart says good things
come to those who wait and I can't
standing I can stand in line forever
stand the
cold glad handed sick and tired all the
later maybe take it B it take it take it
or leave it life and I got to just name
it I got to just name it I got to just
SE oh please oh please oh please oh
please me right cuz my mind won't stop
and my heart says go nobody knows how to
hold me my mind won't stop and my heart
says
[Music]
go
good things must be here yes right here
here right here right
here I won't live this life forever one
time round is all the offer is sick and
tired all the later maybe take it fake
it make it or leave it like
man I got to just name it I got to just
claim it I got to just see oh please oh
please oh please oh please me right cuz
I what I what I but I don't have I what
I have what I have but I don't have you
know that my mind won't stop and my
heart says go nobody knows how to hold
know my mind won't stop and my heart
says go
oh what I can't but I don't have what I
what I can't have what I can't have but
I don't have what I want what I
I I I I but I don't have what I I what I
can't want have but I don't
have what I want
[Music]
[Applause]